ladies and Gentlemen people of the world
we have a very exciting guest today
it's the very Fantastical extremely
talented one and only it's Oliver tree
folks now before you say anything we
gotta figure out we gotta seize this
opportunity yeah we see you all the time
on other people's shows yeah spouting
what might be [__] I don't know it's
not
it's not no because half the [__] you
say doesn't seem real yeah I live a very
eccentric lifestyle well it's time to
find out what is actually real yeah for
real
so we've fitted you with a with a shock
collar that'll shock you if you lie
isn't this how the last Saw movie ended
I never saw it literally never saw one
of the setups I never saw it
nice
um it might have been and that might be
your ending today take it easy but just
to make sure it's all I came here no
character no costume yeah I'm just a
normal guy no we appreciate that we do
appreciate that but we want to figure
out actually for real who you are yeah
and what you're about so we brought in
an expert
this is Jasper hello he designed that
shock hauler
is this safe uh it is safe I didn't
design it my girl ran the last one out
so I had to grab the one from her dog so
it's it's safe
but this thing looks like it's been
jailbroken what kind of dogs do you have
mini Schnauzer oh okay yeah those should
be different kind of jailbroke this
doesn't look like a normal shock collar
yeah what's up with the wires man yeah
why are they exposed it's like a pipe
bomb well I got it from my girl she told
me she got it from her brother he was
talking about family they souped it up
for some race I don't know look let's
get to the to the meat of this okay we
got a few questions for you man okay and
we just wanna you know just to establish
a baseline all right I'm a straight
shooter all right okay Jasper take it
away all right our first question
is Oliver tree your real birth name
that is correct but technically speaking
Oliver tree is my first and middle name
but Oliver tree is yes my actual birth
name okay well
okay next question uh did you grow up
didn't shot it didn't shock him it
didn't shock him
look it up look it up all right we
believe you question two
did you really grow up in the circus yes
I did for the first eight years of my
life and then after that I moved to
Santa Cruz California and I grew up
there
hmm
okay question three mm-hmm
is that your real hair
is it I'm actually curious
yes a lot of people think this is a wig
but this is my real hair it's not
extensions it's not anything other than
hair on a human's head
you can feel it may I yeah
just be gentle
don't oh sorry not so hard you can feel
it sorry yeah that's actually his hair
okay
really get it really get it [__] all
right you know how long it took me to
get this hair ready today
clearly a long time because it's real I
actually can't believe that's your real
hair yeah yeah I'm kind of I'm kind of
impressed kind of how long did it take
to grow that started in covid
damn yep have you ever killed anyone I
prefer not to answer that can you can
you do that
I am being honest I would prefer not to
answer it all right kind of feels like
cheating but that's fine yeah whatever
man question 4B
what is your body count
that's not funny
what just because I have his hair cut I
can't get laid oh I was talking about
murders actually oh oh yeah 4B because
you still killed somebody but we're
still trying to figure out I don't want
to talk about any of the murder stuff
okay the allegations are that's none of
that [__] that look anything I want to
talk to you're right my bad okay all
right got you man next that's the last
question I have for you Mr tree Dr tree
well but tree's your middle name so all
right what's the question let's get this
over with all right last question
what is your favorite podcast
what'd you say I can't hear you what is
your favorite podcast
what did he say what's your favorite
part so what's your favorite podcast
dude that's an interesting question
don't look at the sign don't look at the
sign dude what's the answer my favorite
podcast in the entire world
is
why don't you just say it yeah I've been
weird
stop this not even your drink
that one's actually way better than the
[__] they got me stop stalling I'm not
stalling man what's your favorite
stalling what is your favorite podcast
I'll answer the question okay so answer
it
my favorite podcast in the world stop
first drinking the [__] drink dude
my favorite podcast in the entire world
is
huh
what is your favorite podcast
that one's actually really good enough
what is your favorite bomb what is that
what is your favorite podcast why did
you guys enjoy your favorite podcast
black coffee no dude come on with
straight black dude I'm about to [__]
walk okay all right they just answer the
question answer the question what is
your favorite podcast
okay I'm gonna walk over here
all right
enough enough with the drinks man
what's your favorite podcast what is it
what is your favorite part it's empty
there's nothing in there stop wasting
the Lacroix okay okay I'll answer the
question what's what's the question dude
what is the question I forget the
question I don't even remember the
question is what's the question what is
your favorite podcast what is your
favorite podcast
if he reaches for the [__] drink
Justice smack his hand away
my favorite podcast favorite podcast
is Tiny meat gang
wait stop I knew it unbelievable I knew
it you're a liar
give me that thing give me that thing my
favorite podcast is oh there it goes
again oh yeah what else your music's
really good dude we love it dude yeah
for sure we love him we love your hair
too yeah yeah I know your hair is super
awesome yeah for sure man oh yeah hey
you know what yeah I was being serious
my favorite podcast
stop looking at the sign just tell the
truth and you're fine all right all
right my favorite podcast
is uh
I think yeah it's all the drinks yeah uh
drinks are making me gassy
my favorite book
podcast
are you okay am I all that electricity
in the liquid he might be it's the
Shocker mixed with the Lacroix mixed
with all these different brands of
coffee and I'm lactose intolerant what
was one over here oh that was actually
just straight milk
can I spit here no you can't
my favorite podcast
is the full sun podcast with the milk
boys
what they have a great show no shock
he wasn't lying yeah where is he going
what he's more mad about it than you
guys I mean I'm upset I just don't know
how to process it
is he good
you made him cry are you okay yeah you
all right man um I'm all right what's
wrong
I was just not the way I really wanted
to start the day at 9am in the morning
yeah how did you want to start it I
don't know
maybe not by getting shocked like a
hundred times
well then don't be an [__] yeah I
wasn't being an [__] you guys started
springing on tricky questions
I just don't like getting shocked 100
times at 9am in the morning
my drink which one was yours yeah which
one was yours did they all have your
back wash in them now I did there was a
little back spit
what
oh I put it here
what are you drinking black coffee